okay great well uh thanks everyone for
uh
tuning back in um and alex
wine will tell us about low degree
hardness of random optimization problems
please alex take it away great all right
uh yeah thanks a lot and thanks to the
organizers for uh having me here
so this is joint work with david
gamarnick and akos joganov
so when i say random optimization
problems let me
uh say what i mean by this
so by way of example imagine i give you
a random graph
like an erdos rennie graph and your goal
is to find the largest clique that you
can
or maybe i give you a random ksat
formula and your goal is to find
a assignment that satisfies as many
clauses as possible
or maybe i give you a random degree p
polynomial
and your goal is to find a point on the
unit sphere
in n dimensions that achieves
the largest value possible
so in contrast to some other settings
here there is no
planted solution we're just looking at
totally random data
and um finding you know looking for the
biggest or the best solution that we can
find that
just occurred by random chance
okay so for these types of problems
there's a few different things we might
be interested in
first of all we'd like to know what's
the typical value of the
global optimum with high probability
but we'd also like to know that if we
restrict ourselves to polynomial time
algorithms
what objective value can we reach right
so
i'll call these two thresholds opt and
alg
respectively and the key question that i
want to address
is that sometimes we'll see there are
cases where it seems to be
computationally hard to reach a
particular objective value
and we'd like to understand why and
particularly we'd like to do this
somehow in a unified way that applies to
all kinds of different problems
all at once okay
so this is sort of the motivation and
here's a more concrete
example so the maximum independent set
problem
in a random graph so if we take the
sparse erdos randy graph
with n vertices and average degree d
[Music]
we can ask find a big independent set so
find a set
of independent meaning it's a set of
vertices
that has no edges uh in it no edges
among these vertices
um okay and so
the regime we're going to care about is
where imagine d is a large constant or
in other words i first take n to
infinity with d
fixed and then after that i take d to
infinity
and so in this scaling regime we know
the optimum
the maximum independent set is going to
be a particular
value but algorithmically we only know
how to find
an independent set of half this size and
this is just by a simple
greedy algorithm and the number of years
ago
carb famously asked whether there is a
better algorithm that can close this
factor of two
and we still don't know one and in fact
we've started to realize maybe there
just simply is not
one the first evidence for this was some
kind of structural evidence
saying that the cliques of size larger
than alg
cluster together in a way that makes it
seem like certain algorithms should fail
more precisely we now know that
so-called local algorithms can achieve
the value alg
but cannot do any better than that so a
local algorithm
is basically something where each vertex
only gets to look at its
local neighborhood in the graph of say a
constant radius
and make some decision about whether it
should be in the independence or not
just by looking at its neighbors along
with some iid
variables attached to each node this is
also called the factors of iid
model okay
here's just a second example of a more
continuous nature
where we look at basically maximizing a
random
degree p homogeneous polynomial over the
sphere
so this is also called the spherical p
spin model
the input you get is basically um
this tensor of of
values this uh this y right think of it
as like um
n by n by n um array of all the
coefficients of your polynomial
and we want to just find a unit vector
that maximizes this tensor form
okay and this is scaled in a way so that
the true
optimum global optimum is going to be
some constant depending on p
and algorithmically the value we know
how to reach is some other constant
also depending on p and these are
strictly different
uh so long as p is bigger than three so
for p equals two this is like a simple
eigenvalue problem
[Music]
but apart from that we do not know how
to find the global
maximum and again there is some evidence
that maybe we can't
fundamentally and this is in this case
that this class of approximate message
passing algorithms
can achieve precisely this value alg
but i cannot go beyond this
okay so you know what's missing here
like i've shown you some
some results that are quite nice already
and so on a philosophical level i'd like
to address the question of how do we
give the best
evidence that there's no better
algorithms
it's sort of beyond the current state of
complexity theory to
really you know prove there's no
algorithms for this type of problem
so we want to give some kind of rigorous
evidence
whatever this means exactly and so prior
work has ruled out certain classes of
algorithms like the local methods or the
amp
but we should ask ourselves whether we
expect these to be optimal
and maybe we'd be concerned a bit
because for instance we know
amp is actually not optimal for for a
different problem called tensor pca
which is really just the planted version
of the
p spin model so it's the piecemen model
where you have kind of a planted signal
so maybe we're worried that it's not
optimal for the non-planted version as
well
and we'd also really would kind of like
a unified framework for lower bounds and
all these different problems
so the issue with local algorithms is
they only really make sense for sparse
graphs
and so this is not going to yield sort
of a general
purpose framework and so here's sort of
you know the key
idea that we propose here as a solution
is um that we can instead prove lower
bounds against a larger class of
algorithms
namely low degree polynomials and this
is a class of algorithms that contains
local algorithms contains amp algorithms
contains
uh the best known algorithms for tensor
pca
and various other things and so um
you know generally speaking we sort of
uh
believe or conjecture that these are
going to be
optimal and optimal class of algorithms
among polynomial time algorithms
okay so what exactly do i mean by these
low degree
algorithms uh so it's
just um just low degree polynomials
so a multivariate polynomial that takes
in m
inputs and outputs and outputs
um or if you prefer it's really a
you know a tuple of a few different
polynomials one for each output
and each one of these
is uh is real valued
and so we should think of the input here
as just being whatever input we're given
in our problem so that could be an
entire graph
like one variable for each edge
and the output we should imagine for
instance is going to be maybe a vector
and we want it to be approximately the
indicator vector of some independent set
and you know i said low degree but i
haven't really specified how much
you should imagine for this talk that
low degree means like order of
log n where n is the dimension i'll
justify
y a bit later and so
you know why is this sort of an
interesting class of algorithms well one
reason is that
a bunch of different things can be
captured by this
so for example if i imagine my input is
some matrix
here's a bunch of things i could do with
low degree algorithms one is power
iteration
so starting with say the all ones vector
i could multiply by my matrix a bunch of
times to get an approximation of the
leading eigenvector
[Music]
it turns out i could also do a constant
number of rounds of approximate message
passing
which is some kind of iterative scheme
that i won't get into the
details of uh it turns out you can also
do local algorithms
and uh you know crucially you can also
do some pre-transformation of your data
so i can you know i don't have to do
power iteration on the matrix i'm given
i can instead build some other matrix
whose entries are
say constant degree polynomials in the
original data
and then do power iteration on that so
this lets me capture
various um you know fancier spectral
methods like the
non-backtracking block matrix or tensor
unfolding
and so on um
and sort of the reason for the log n is
that
um typically you need about login rounds
of power iteration
if your matrix is uh well conditioned
although there's also some situations
where even a constant number of
iterations
is enough
um okay so these are this is what i mean
by a low degree
algorithm
and so i guess i should say a bit more
about where the motivation for this
comes from
really the motivation for these low
degree algorithms comes from a line of
existing work
for planted problems so for problems
that have a planted signal
say planted clique sparse pca and so on
there's this uh been this very
influential line of work
that's sort of introduced this concept
of low-degree algorithms
and it's now been shown that for a whole
bunch of different problems
like the ones listed here we know that
low degree polynomials are as powerful
as the best known
polynomial time algorithms right so this
has two
sides to it in sort of the easy regime
where we know
an algorithm um then we also know
that there's a low degree polynomial
that works typically some kind of
spectral method
um and on the other hand in the
conjectured hard regime we're typically
able to prove that
low degree that no low degree polynomial
succeeds
right so this gives sort of a nice
framework for explaining what makes
these problems
uh easy for some regime of parameters
and hard for
another regime and so
the main idea of this work is to kind of
take this
whole theory that's been widely
successful for planted problems and to
see if we can do the same thing for
non-planted problems and hopefully
uh use low degree polynomials as a kind
of unified explanation for what makes
all of these types of problems either
planted nor unplanted
um what makes these part in some cases
and easy and others
okay yeah feel free to stop me with
any questions
so let me try to explain a bit
what some of our actual results are
so this is just um you know remembering
the problem set up for this
spherical p spin model so remember
there's some constant algo smaller than
some other constant opt
and um you know what we're able to show
in this case
is that no low degree polynomial can can
optimize all the way to the global
maximum
right so there's you know some small
absolute constant epsilon
and uh okay i'll be a bit more formal
now about what exactly does it mean for
a polynomial to optimize this thing
um so for technical reasons where p
needs to be even
[Music]
and we're imagining um you know a
polynomial that takes your whole
tensor as input and it outputs some
vector
and the idea is that that vector is
supposed to be like your v
[Music]
um and i'm saying that no low degree
polynomial
can uh can succeed with with high
probability
where here's sort of the definition of
success
someone needs to do two things to
succeed
um first of all it needs to actually
achieve a good a good value
and here is uh what i'm calling this h
of
v here this is the hamiltonian or the
objective value right so we we want
in order for a polynomial to succeed you
know of course the output needs to
achieve a good
objective function but then also it
needs to be like normalized in the
approximately in the way that we wanted
it to be for the problem
okay and so we're able to rule out you
know any such
algorithm or we're able to rule out any
such algorithm that succeeds with
with some explicit uh fairly high
probability
[Music]
um this is sort of there for technical
conditions
um but really you know in the easy
regime in
when we're below alg we know you can
succeed with
even much higher than this probability
or with much smaller error probability
so this is sort of uh
does not seem like a too big of an issue
one question yeah hey so
here the probability is for every
polynomial right so
or is it like with this probability for
no polynomial this condition holds
um let's see so there is there is no
prob
there is no polynomial that has the
property
that with very high probability it
succeeds
yeah sorry if this is written in a bit
of a confusing way
um yeah good other questions
um okay so let me
oops
um talk now about the independent set
where here we can actually uh say
something a bit stronger
so if you recall there is these you know
the actual biggest independent set
is twice as large as the biggest one we
sort of know how to find
or the conjectured algorithmic threshold
so here we can actually get sort of the
tight threshold
saying that no low degree polynomial can
get
better than this threshold out
and and uh you know we also know the
converse that low degree polynomials can
get
you know uh alg minus epsilon
and so we've sort of characterized the
uh the exact
threshold where low degree polynomials
succeed and it sort of coincides with
the
conjectured fundamental one
um so again i'll be a bit more formal
about this so here now we're thinking
about polynomials that take in a graph
output a vector the vector is sort of
supposed to be an indicator vector for
a big independent set
and again you know no such polynomial
can succeed with high probability
where succeed means a couple of
different things
um the first item is just saying you
know most of the output values should be
either close to zero or close to one
since it's supposed to be an indicator
vector and then the second point is
saying that
if i take the ones where it's output one
if i take those vertices
that should be approximately an
independent set
so i have it a bit informal here but
essentially we allow for a small number
of errors so it's allowed to
you know mess up on a couple of vertices
where
the independence constraint is violated
or something
but then we're just going to kind of
throw these out
so we have sort of a you know it's this
definition is sort of a soft notion of
success and this is um set up in a way
so that
low degree polynomials can actually
achieve this
in the easy regime like below alg
okay any questions about this
so for the rest of the time i want to
tell you
um you know how to actually prove such a
thing
how do you prove that all low-degree
polynomials fail at
a task like this
and so let's first you know
recap what happens for the
you know the more classical setting of
the planted problems
so low degree polynomials have already
been well studied in these planted
problems
there's kind of two different types of
planted problems you can imagine there's
detection which is just about
distinguishing you know is there a
planted signal versus is there not
and there's also the recovery problem
which is you know actually finding the
signal
um low degree polynomials have been
studied for both of these
and the proof techniques here uh turn
out to boil down to actually just
sort of straightforward linear algebra
in some sense
like there's a direct computation
that you know here it involves taking
the likelihood ratio and projecting onto
the space of
low-degree polynomials um for the
recovery there's a bit of a
trick you have to do first but it then
[Music]
boils down also to kind of a direct
computation
but that's sort of in contrast to what
i'll say here
so for these random optimization
problems those type of techniques
do not seem to work at all and we need a
totally different approach
[Music]
and so what it will basically be is this
there's going to be two ingredients the
first one is that low-degree polynomials
are
stable in some sense you know roughly
speaking if you perturb the input a
little bit the output
um won't change too much in some sense
and the second one is some kind of
structural property
of the large independent sets in the
random graph
or of uh more generally the space of
solutions
so this is um something called the
overlap gap property and its
generalizations and so the versions of
this we'll need are most directly
inspired by
by this line of work here
okay so i'll get a bit more into the
details now unless there are
more questions
so the first ingredient is the fact i
said that low degree polynomials are
stable
uh okay so i'm going to focus on the
independent set problem for the proof
because uh this one's a bit simpler and
you know we're able to prove a bit
stronger things here
and so okay i'm going to imagine that y
is just an iid
bernoulli variable you know i'm
eventually going to think of this as
being the random error runny graph with
one variable
per edge but for this slide we don't
need the graph structure and we can just
think of it as
a bunch of bernoullis
and i need to define something called
the interpolation path
and so all this is is basically that
at uh step i
of the path i'm going to oops i don't
seem to be drawing
at step i i am going to resample
you know variable y i
um or in other words the ith edge of the
graph
is going to be resampled so i start with
just um
iid bernoulli at the first step i
resample the first you know the first
edge of the graph
and then i resample the second edge of
the graph
and so on and so on and here m is just
going to be
the total number of edges for us the
total number of variables
right so i'm thinking of y as being
as having m components
um all right and here you know for the
graph the edges are just listed in some
arbitrary order that's kind of fixed
ahead of time
okay so that's the interpolation path
and now i'm going to
fix some low degree polynomial
and i'm going to call a step of this
path c bad if f's output changes a lot
during that step right if the output of
f jumps suddenly
at one step to the next i'm going to say
that step is bad
and you know how much to jump is sort of
measured
as compared to f's typical size
our typical norm all right that is a
vector valued okay and here is the main
uh
the main result on stability that we're
going to use
that you know if i draw this random
so f is fixed but this this path is is
drawn randomly
i'm saying that the probability that
there is no bad edge
you know is at least something so this
something
is um is actually is fairly small this
is just some non-trivial probability
but that will be enough for our purposes
um so what it's basically saying is that
with non-trivial probability over the
path
f's output is kind of smooth there's
never a big jump
okay
[Music]
so this is a somewhat subtle sense in
which low-degree polynomials are stable
you know you can notice that you can't
hope to put high probability here
because imagine for instance a dictator
function
[Music]
um you know there's a decent chance that
along this path i'm going to flip the
one
important input bit and that will cause
the entire output to flip
but you know there's going to be a
non-trivial probability that i simply
i might just not flip that that one
important bit
okay so questions about this
um this part of the result
so let me move on now to the second
ingredient which is the
this overlap gap property
um okay so what does the overlap cop
property say
so with hybrid so now i'm just for now
imagine one graph
with high probability over one random
graph there do not exist
a pair of a pair of independent sets
with the following properties okay so
they're both independent sets
individually they are both large
um okay so for a start i'm going to
prove a weaker result
that doesn't get the sharp threshold but
but gets
uh this threshold instead so think of
we're trying to show that low degree
polynomials cannot find uh
an independent set of larger than this
value
and i'm going to use fee as this this
shorthand for uh the scale at which
things happen
so if you remember that uh opt is just
is just two times v and l
is just um v okay
and this threshold is somewhere in the
middle
so think of these as two large
independent sets so two independents
two large independent sets
whose intersection is a very particular
value
or you know within some small interval
right so it's saying that this never
happens
so you know what's going on here
so two large independent sets
you know they're allowed to they're
allowed to intersect a lot they're
allowed to be
overlapping quite a bit and they're also
allowed to be
you know nearly disjoint or only
overlapping a little bit
but what's never allowed to happen is
sort of this
particular intermediate case
when they're um you know
when their overlap is some precise value
fee
right this um this never happens
for a typical random graph you can never
find two large independent sets that
have
this particular intermediate overlap
um okay so morally speaking this can be
thought of saying that somehow the
independent sets the large independent
sets uh separate into clusters
you know for some given independent set
the other ones are either nearby meaning
they're kind of in the same cluster
or they're far away meaning that they're
kind of in different clusters
um and the way to prove this is actually
uh very
simple and elegant this is due to
kumarik in sudan
and it's just a first moment method so
all you do is compute the expected
number
of of of pairs s t that satisfy
all these things right this is just
kind of a calculation you can do and you
can see that
if you choose this intersection just
right
that the expected number of these things
will be will be tiny will be
exponentially small
and so we now know that with very high
probability
you know the very high probability is
even
you know one minus you know it's
uh whoops minus omega n
so exponentially small probability of
this happening
um and this will sort of be important
because this exponentially small
probability we'll need to
it's important that this will be smaller
than that non-trivial probability from
the
previous slide okay is this
overlap gap property clear
[Music]
so that was actually kind of a just a
warm up and what we really need is a
slightly more sophisticated um version
of this
um that's inspired by a couple of works
including some prior work by
uh by kumarnik and jaganov
um where they basically realized that
the if you take a
more sophisticated version of this ogp
which i'll describe now
this can somehow be used to rule out any
sufficiently stable
algorithm okay so what is this this
ensemble
ogp so now i'm going to
draw this this interpolation path like i
described earlier
where you start with a random graph and
then you resample
the edges one by one right where so m is
just the total number of edges
each edge gets uh resampled exactly once
and the order is just
some fixed but arbitrary order on the
edges
okay and this more advanced ogp
is now saying you know even now there
still does not exist
two independent sets that are both large
and both have that particular forbidden
overlap
but now what's sort of different is that
now the
s is allowed to come be an independent
set in one of these graphs
t is allowed to be an independent
setting plus in a possibly different
graph
right so even if i allow s and t to come
from two different graphs
you still can never find this this
pattern
um okay and the proof is again sort of
is the same
is just using the first moment method
and the bottleneck to proving this
actually is just the case where i and j
are equal it's somehow
only easier to show this when they come
from different graphs
the reason is you know imagine for
instance if the two graphs are just
independent you're basically
um any two independent sets
you know one from the first and one from
the second basically can never intersect
very much
just because the graphs are so different
um okay so is this definition clear
so now i will
move on and tell you how to actually use
this
um okay so let's now put the two
ingredients together so i'll prove to
you
that no low degree polynomial
can can achieve this objective value
right which is somewhere in between how
can opt so this is like a sub-optimal
result but it will
illustrate the main purpose and i'll
show you
afterwards how to improve it to the
optimal threshold
um okay so what are we going to do well
let's sort of assume on the contrary
that we had some
polynomial that succeeds at finding
these large independent sets
um okay and what are we going to do
we're going to
you know imagine constructing this these
um you know random in uh correlated
sequence of graphs
where we resample a different edge at
each step like before
and um and what we're going to do is
just apply
you know we have our function f let's
just imagine applying f to
e to each of them right and so in each
case we're going to get some independent
set
um and sort of uh
fact number one that we need is that
the the first one the one that comes
from the first
graph and the one that comes from the
last graph sort of have to be far apart
i've drawn them here as disjoint you
know really they have to be
just nearly disjoint but why is this
this is just another fact you can show
using the first
moment method because these two graphs
are actually just
independent right we've resampled all
the edges
because the graphs are independent there
simply just cannot be
um you know this new graph will not have
any independent sets that correlate with
with whichever one you output here
um okay and now
recall that um low degree polynomials
have the stability pro
pro property so with some non-trivial
probability
the output of f is going to be stable
meaning that
the independent set does not change too
much at each step
right so the first one and then the next
one can only change
a little bit from there and so on right
so i can't uh
change too many vertices at each each
step along this path
but now actually this this contradicts
the overlap gap property
right because if i need to sort of go
from this first set to this
far away set in sort of a continuous way
well there must have been you know some
set along the way
where the intersection with the original
set
is exactly this forbidden
value fee right or you know
approximately close enough to it
right and so by this sort of
interpolation argument
we can find uh we know that somewhere
along this path we're going to find a
contradiction to the
overlap gap property
okay
um any questions
so that proves um this is the result for
this
sub-optimal threshold let me now
tell you how to improve this
okay so how are we going to improve the
threshold
so the idea from this is um
you know at a high level is kind of
inspired by a work of raman and virag
who proved to the analogous result for
local algorithms
and the idea is instead of using this
overlap gap property right this was a
property about two different sets
we're going to have to use a more
sophisticated property that involves
more than two sets
so we're going to think about structural
properties that involve a large number
of different inter
independent sets um
okay so let me define exactly what is
the
key structural property we'll use
so again um like i said a bunch of times
we're going to
imagine sampling the same thing start
with a random graph
resample every edge but here's actually
a bit different
notice i'm going up to lm instead of
just m
so i'm actually just repeating the whole
process l times
where l is some large constant right so
resample all the edges
one by one then in the next phase
resample all the edges again one by one
and then repeat this l times
and you know given this whole sequence
of different
correlated graphs there does not exist
a sequence of sets
such that um such that what each one of
them is an independent set
in in one of these random graphs
you know it gets to sort of choose which
one
independently they're all big where big
now
is really the the correct target
threshold that we're hoping for
[Music]
and now this third property is sort of
the key one
okay so what is it saying this is saying
like the number of new vertices
that each set introduces needs to be
in this particular interval so it needs
to be small but not too small
um okay this last property is only for k
bigger than one
of course the first set is going to
introduce a bunch of new vertices
right but let's say we have um you know
a bunch of these
sets so far
um what's this saying is that you know
the next the next
s sub k
whoops somehow that disappeared
but if i have say these sets so far
the next independent set that i
add to the sequence you know the number
of
new vertices needs to be um precisely
needs to be kind of this precise value
okay so uh quite small so maybe i've
drawn it too big in the picture there
but okay this um and so the theorem
going along with the structural property
is that you know it turns out by
the first moment method that that no
such thing exists
that there does not exist a sequence
of sets
um satisfying these these things
and so how do we use this to rule out um
low degree polynomials
well like before we're going to sort of
suppose we had a stable algorithm that
finds these large independent sets
[Music]
and we need to use this stable algorithm
to construct an instance of the
forbidden structure
and that would be a contradiction
right and so how would we use this
stable algorithm to output
a forbidden structure
right so it's actually not so difficult
to see maybe
right the stable algorithm is sort of
you know as you modify the graph the
stable algorithm outputs some
independent set that only changes
gradually as you modify the graph
and so all we're going to do is
basically just wait until this condition
holds
right we'll we'll pick we'll take the
first set automatically
as our you know the whatever comes from
y0 will be our s0
and then we'll just we'll move along
this interpolation path of graphs
until we hit a set that introduces just
the right number of new vertices
and then keep that one and then keep
going go again until we introduce
another set that introduces
the the right number of new vertices and
keep that one so on
right and that will let us construct
this there's just one
sort of caveat left is that we need to
make sure the algorithm isn't going to
just stay in one place
the whole time and never introduce any
new vertices right
and so we also need the fact that after
after m steps right after resampling the
whole graph
the algorithm is forced to move to a new
place
because there just simply won't be any
independent sets
left that are in the same place okay and
that's sort of why we need to
that's why this l is the same as this l
actually
like the number of times we need to
resample the whole graph is l because
at each of these phases we're going to
be guaranteed to to pick up
one set in order to construct our
forbidden structure
okay so that's essentially the proof
any questions about that
okay so i'll wrap up by giving a couple
of comments
so i mostly talked about the independent
step problem here
for the p spin problem um
you know we can prove some similar
things but things are actually a bit
more difficult there
you can't just use the first moment
method to prove ogp
this actually instead leverages um
some pretty sophisticated results from
spin glass theory
and we don't currently know how to prove
like the sharp results
of you know getting exactly the correct
threshold or the correct objective value
so that's one
open question is to you know find the
exact objective value reachable by
low degree algorithms for these
uh spin glass problems
another point is that you know we have
we've ruled out low degree algorithms
but we've actually really ruled out
any algorithm that's sufficiently stable
in some sense
and this includes some other classes of
things like for the pspin
it includes for instance this longivan
dynamics which is some kind of a
continuous time markov chain
um you know as long as you run it only
for say a logarithmic number of
iterations
and finally i see this as being
you know part of a solution to a much
larger meta question
which is that we have all these
different heuristics for what makes
problems hard
like the low degree method but we also
have things like sum of squares
statistical queries
overlapped gap property the cavity
method etc etc
and uh establishing uh finding you know
rigorous connections between these
things is sort of an
interesting direction and so here we've
shown in some sense that a certain
variant of
the overlap gap property implies that
something is loadedly
hard
and i'll leave you just with a list of
some references
for the low degree method more uh more
generally in a couple different
settings so both uh you know detection
problems recovery problems and then
what i talked today about today was the
last one the optimization problems
um yeah that's all thanks for your
attention
thanks alex there's a question here by
arson vasilian who's asking if the
stability property that you presented
about
low degree polynomials if that statement
was tight
oh yeah that's a good point um
yeah in terms of the error probability
or like the non-trivial probability
there
um yeah i think essentially it is tight
like
one example to maybe have in mind is
imagine
p is just a half
and so um i want to
you know to show this is tight i want to
construct some low degree polynomial for
which
you know the probability really is is
quite close to this
and the polynomial i will take is just
going to be
um like the product of the first
or rather the xor i guess of the
first um
d things or you know any
pick any d coordinates and
and take just the xor of those
and so what's going on there you know if
if the
if the inputs so this this just takes
values 0 and 1 as outputs it's just a
one
one single output you know if if the
if the value ever switches from zero to
one then then
you lose then that's a that's c bad
[Music]
and so you know the only way to not lose
is if
you never flip and as like if along
going along this path you never change
any of these d
coordinates you know you're allowed to
change the other n minus d
but not those d and so the probability
that you don't flip any of those d
bits is basically going to be like you
know one half to the
d which p to the d which is basically
what's here
um does this answer the question
yes um there's also so
um i think ronan had a question
he had raised his hand uh
yeah so i asked you two quick questions
uh
i guess the first is your
your proof doesn't seem to rule out that
there exists
like two low-degree polynomials
such that for for most graphs
one of these low degree polynomials will
point to a good independent set
because like you can kind of jump from
one to the other
can can you kind of fix that and and
also say there doesn't exist you know
a small family of low degree polynomials
such that you know one of them has a
good answer with high probability
uh okay yeah that's an interesting
question i haven't
really thought about this
um i mean you know maybe one solution
would be if you really had
this family of polynomials the hope was
that i could comb i would hope i could
combine these into one
bigger polynomial that just always works
um but maybe this is not uh obvious how
to
do this exactly
[Music]
um but yeah it kind of seems like an
obstacle
obstacle to the proof right because if
you have two of them you can kind of
jump from one to the other in the middle
of this interpolation path
and then
um yeah yeah i agree with you
um right i mean i don't
yeah i certainly don't know of any
situation where an algorithm like this
actually is known to help sure
yeah it doesn't make sense yeah i don't
i just wonder yeah i don't know how to
rule out
yeah i don't know how to rule out such a
thing and a second quick question
can you like is there a quick way to
explain
how to implement the greedy like local
algorithm
as a law degree polynomial
yeah basically what you have to do is um
right so the first step is if you take
the greedy algorithm you can approximate
that as a local algorithm
by kind of looking at a large constant
radius and sort of imagine running the
local algorithm or imagine running the
greedy algorithm
um right if you have this you have this
local algorithm where each vertex looks
at a constant
radius you want to turn this into a low
degree polynomial
um it's essentially by like a um
by brute force enumerating all the
possible neighborhoods that this
one vertex could have right these
neighborhoods are only like constant
size
so with a constant degree polynomial i
can basically check
you know all the possible cases of what
my neighborhood would be but then you
you still have to
iterate this so you're saying it's kind
of
closed under iterations or
um you have to iterate this
what do you mean by iterate uh which i
i i just mean you know it's just there
there's the loop of the
of the greedy algorithm i guess i guess
i'm just
like like also the local algorithm any
local algorithm is kind of like
you're on a loop i guess so i mean you
you have to enumerate
the different neighborhoods but then
once you pick the next point
you have to do it again i guess okay
yeah yeah i think
i think i understand your point yeah so
what's really happening is that i'm
approximating so i'm not going to write
the greedy algorithm yeah the greedy
algorithm is very sequential
i'm instead going to approximate it by a
very parallel sort of thing
where each vertex looks at some large
constant
neighborhood and its decision is just
some function of what's happening in
that neighborhood and every vertex does
this
in parallel that makes a lot of sense
okay
thanks sure
there's also a couple of questions in
the q a i don't know can you see the
questions alex so do you want me to read
them out to you
uh oh yeah i can see it technical
barriers in ruling out low degree
polynomials that work
correctly with a constant probability
yeah that's a good question like
oh maybe both of these questions are
kind of about the same
um yeah so
as is the current result is only rolling
out probably
polynomials that succeed with fairly
high probability
you know not just one minus the low of
one but really
um you know one minus n to the d
or something you know really there's
sort of a trade-off between the degree
that you can rule out and the error
probability but uh essentially the
technical barrier
is that first of all there's this
non-trivial
um there's this non-trivial probability
coming from the stability label lemma
and so the algorithm's
failure probability needs to be smaller
than that non-trivial probability
in order to have a non-zero right you
want the proof needs to have like a
non-zero probability that you get a
contradiction
um so there's that and there's also the
issue that just i've union bounded over
the algorithm succeeding at a bunch of
different steps of this
interpolation process so yeah i mean
it's a good question i
it would be great to to improve this
error probability but i don't really
have
ideas for how to do this
okay well there are more questions
the gather town will be open and if now
we'll take a break
until i think 11 30
where dhiraj nagaraj will tell us about
face transitions for detecting latent
geometry
and random graphs okay
oh see you everyone